i want to um talk about this just for
one second this
thing bothered me a lot there was an ad
in or is it tweet
i guess both burger king was trying to
be funny in an ad and i think they were
funny
they were talking about a program they
have to increase the number of women
chefs
there aren't a comparative number of
women chefs in the world maybe they
should get more opportunities maybe
there's a reason why they don't and we
should
address that that's what they were
trying to say so they had an
ad women belong in the kitchen
oh wow i didn't see it and of course you
know the
hit the fan the usual suspects
and i just want to say this this is
what's wrong with us
it's like if you don't get the joke here
then you're stupid
you don't get subtlety you don't get
humor you don't get perspective
and and if you do and you're pretending
that you don't just so you can have
something to be pissed off
at then you're both ways you're gross
yeah
well i'm going to have to call a foul on
that play i don't think this is a
joke that's as good as you're saying
that it is
no it's an ad it's every day it's it's
not a monologue joke
no no no i know what you mean but i mean
i hadn't seen that
if i just saw that i'm like what the
is burger king doing
but then you would read it and that's
the point it's got your attention that's
what advertisements
nyu i think has the right take on this
and that gestures should be taken with
the intent that they're given
and this was meant to highlight yeah
sexism
exactly fortunately what we have in my
industry is guilty of this
we've created an industrial shaming
culture where there's money
in dunking on people and saying making a
caricature of comments and then using
that to extract to an ugly place so you
can get virtue points
because the moment you're offended on
our country it means you're right and
where we have
the universities is we need to be
graduating not woesters but
warriors and that is people who are here
doc i'm giving you an applause now
and and we need to look at those ads and
we need to look at those ads and say
does that humor work
why didn't it work and have a thoughtful
conversation and move on but not this
industrial
dunking complex well here at real time
we thought it did work we thought it
worked so well
that we created some other ones for
other companies
uh in the same style would you like to
see the music these are just
yeah we're just look if guts people
attention so we thought
other companies could use for example
oscar meyer could have uh nothing says
summer like putting a wiener in your bun
it's provocative it gets you thinking
about it
[Applause]
hooters when you're here you're looking
at tits
that's fine funny because it's true
that's right
uh grape nuts we have ways of making you
uh the army it's not murder if the
people you kill are foreign
flags our roller coasters are great for
women with kids and pregnant ladies who
don't want them
[Applause]
uh american airlines let's get this
straight
you don't like us and we don't like you
[Applause]
great
pfizer we vaccinated grandpa and made
his dick harder you're welcome we're
sorry
amen and of course the republican party
no seriously a woman's place really is
in the kitchen
you